so the Troubles man makes for himself
in the thirties nature adds disasters of
her own hurricanes floods droughts across
the Great Plains from the Texas Panhandle
to the Canadian border the exhausted earth
broken by the plow parched and eroded begins
to blow away in great black blizzards
the dust storms bring darkness at norm
a lifetime turned to dust a way of life and by
the thousands they abandon their homes flee the
Dust Bowl the approved of Oklahoma give a name
to the new breed of dispossessed Americans Okies
John Steinbeck tells the tale that is told
of the Okies and he calls it The Grapes of
Wrath they took the migrant way to the West
in the daylight they scuttled like bugs to the
wetland and as the dark clustered like bugs
near to shelter into water and because they
were lonely and perplexed because they had
all come from a place of sadness and worry
and defeat and because they were all going to
a new mysterious place they huddled together
they talked together they shared their lives
they were not farm men anymore but migrant men